I came to London when I was 18 and went
to the BFI and haunted an editor until
he finally let me fail some trims and
then eventually give me a job as a
trainee and it was in the days of film
so this thing is kind of assistant heavy
and then I joined the BBC and the rest
is history of load on from there
that's a really difficult question I
think I think something like this thing
in detective I loved the originality of
it and edge of darkness you know they're
all of a certain period because that's
what that suppose when I look back and I
think of what what what give me the
desire to be an editor and it's things
like that the originality and the
storytelling of them but then you can go
right back to Doctor Who and the way it
used to frame a would be brilliant it's
a lots of different programs for
different reasons and I think it's just
the power of the program that it has
over me that it can affect me in someone
where is more than a specific
what advice would I give somebody that's
a difficult question but I think it's
just be determined you've got to love it
and just be determined keep going be
nice to people that's the other thing um
and yeah just don't give up just just
keep at it and just know what you do